Canha pressure to 140 this is the deep
flight super falcon and underwater
submersible that can go as deep as 1,200
feet still going down but what makes it
really special are wide nearly nine-foot
wings that help it fly beneath the
surface the master bottle I did is
marine engineer Graham Hawkes he's been
building underwater vehicles for decades
like the Mantis which he actually
piloted in the James Bond film for your
eyes only now his team builds personal
subs for private clients with deep
pockets how much does one of these cost
well they're hand-built so they're very
expensive today's 1.7 million with a
price tag like that plus the full year
it takes to build one it's not a
surprise that there are only three
currently flying the high seas Tom
Perkins was the first one to walk in a
workshop on what one Sir Richard Branson
Steve Fossett had one and now Deitrick
redbull what about Elon Musk well of
those guys that are going in space there
are a hundred and eighty degrees I've
cooked everything we need for our future
food space minerals is in the ocean Park
says what makes his design so special is
the way it can fly around to move with
the sea life with Richard Branson in the
bag I was supposed to be training him to
fly we were down off Guadalupe and right
off that wing was a shock as big as we
were a big great white shot awesome
alright try
I feel like I'm in a sci-fi movie
for now the deep flex and mercy balls
are still a toy for the ultra-wealthy
but as the technology advances Hawkes
and his team hope they'll become a go-to
for ocean tourism or even commercial
transportation we live on an aquatic
planet and we don't have access to it
and now we're flying in that space it's
pretty cool